there are performers who have built
their whole career doing magic on TV and
can't really perform live at all don't
really have chops and skills and people
watch those shows and seem to enjoy them
I don't think it's magic I don't think
it's valid and not because they're doing
camera tricks which they are and not
because they're using plants which they
are and not because of using editing
tricks which they are the problem is
simply that what you've seen on that
screen what you're competing with I mean
once you've shown avatar on video what
does sleight of hand mean it means
nothing and you can't keep telling
people we're not cheating no honest we
really mean this what does that matter
when your job is to lie you know the
most amazing trick I could ever do for
you is to be from one place to another
place instantly and that's done about
three times a minute on every TV show
even the news so I don't think you can
do that whereas in the theater tell her
and I don't have to spend a moment
saying we're not using camera tricks
because what we're doing there in that
room is following the rules of physics
and the rules of time that you've dealt
with since birth and that makes it
bypass a certain kind of intellect that
makes it fascinating to me that's what I
think but there are many people that
watch chris angel' and go woof that's a
magic trick you know it's not to me but
they go it is so they're not wrong they
just you know have a different
perception of what video does than I do
I mean there are people that will watch
things on Chris's show that to me are
crystal clear how they're being done and
they seem to fool people I mean if you
want a very simple example if you go out
on the street with your camera and you
take a deck of cards and you let the
person open the cards shuffle them clean
deck nothing reach in pick out a card
peek at it put it down and use
say is that the seven of diamonds if you
go out on the street in New York and do
that for two hours eventually you'll be
right you know you don't have to do any
other cheats other than editing just
pick the time it works you know
show us the time it works and you've
done magic and you don't have to design
any of that you know so to me that's
really clear whenever I'm watching TV I
have a very real sense that I'm watching
uh different tries that the same thing
stuck together and with that sense in my
heart with my sense in my heart that
when you're watching DeNiro do it take
that he might have done that 15 times
it's very different for me than watching
an actor in the theater that I know is
going directly into what he's doing now
from what he did ten minutes ago because
we were both in the room in real time
I think it's an entirely different thing
but most people don't
well every night I mean I would say a
hundred percent of the time it all
depends on your definition of flub
you're always wanting to be a little
better one of the great things that
Michael gudo who's the head writer on
and also a juggler in the in
the Lance Burton show uh Michael gudo
said that that variety arts were for
people who watch the movie Groundhog Day
and thought it looked like a good thing
it's wonderful to do things over and
over again to be able to do them right
and you're always striving to do them
better uh we have had tricks not work
we've had embarrassment with that not
often but the thing I'm most proud of in
my career is that in 35 years of doing
shows not tell they're not me but as
importantly no one that works with us
has ever been injured seriously and by
seriously I mean a hospital overnight
you know you're allowed to cut yourself
you can do that you know you can within
my morality you can even break a bone we
haven't had that happen but within my
morality you can but people who get
badly injured in show business that is
that's wrong and the idea of doing stuff
that's really dangerous is to me um
distasteful the idea of magic and
performance is to celebrate life and
health and when you do our movie that is
supposedly full of violence the
representation of violence and no one
gets hurt that's a celebration
everything beautiful when you do a movie
or a performance where someone really
does get hurt
it's it's in a certain SART istic it's a
violation of humanity I don't know about
this trend that David and Chris do or
they do stuff that is supposed to
convince people they really hurt them
selves or that they're really suffering
that to me is is not beautiful I'm not
interested in that what interests me is
the fact that teller and I do the bullet
catch at the end of our show or we fire
357 magnums into each other's faces and
ostensibly catch the bullets and saying
that that's a trick and bragging that
we've never been hurt and bragging that
we can't be hurt is it such a good trick
to me is beautiful